all right hello everybody that's right I
don't need that
welcome to the Lucasfilm games post
mortem this is the first company post
mortem that GDC is done and I'm really
happy that they've given us this
privilege as a few more people are
filtering in let me just ask a few
questions in the audience there well
first of all I'm Noah falstein I'm gonna
be our moderator today and we've got a
distinguished panel of five of the very
first people who were at Lucasfilm games
that later became LucasArts
entertainment and this all came about
pretty much last year around this time
LucasArts was sold off to Disney and for
a lot of us were there at the in the
early years it was a really poignant
moment and got us reflecting a lot and
we've had many requests for interviews
and and done some panels and things and
we're having a great time reminiscing
but also wondering questions about
things like what was it that made it so
special at the time and could that be
recreated and that seemed like a good
basis for a talk here at GDC which is
really what brought us here but before
we begin I'm just curious about a few
things first of all how many of you have
played some of the old Lucasfilm games
LucasArts thank you very much and I have
to say when we were making these things
you know and you told us that you know
30 35 years later people would still be
playing those old games you know it
would have been pretty hard to believe
how many people actually you know this
is the thing now if all the same hands
go up this is going to be a little bit
daunting how many people actually worked
at LucasArts at one time or at others or
in this audience okay not quite so many
all right there we go what do you know
people besides our company actually
played our games it was good work all
right so let's get going here first I'm
going to give some intros and and each
person is going to tell you a little bit
about their perspective and background
we're going to begin here with a little
video and I don't
often put video in my slide so I'm
hoping everything's gonna work here
there you go little play from ball
blazer one of our first two games and to
talk about that and more importantly
about his role in being the person who
started up the company and got everybody
underway is Peter Langston who I've got
some reasonably embarrassing pictures of
most of us so Peter wanted to tell
people a little bit about what it was
like to get things started what some of
the hurdles you went through is you one
thread perhaps okay well I wrote my
first computer game in 1965 I think and
as a being a computer professional
systems analyst and college teacher I
continued writing games throughout until
about say 1982 when I was pretty well
known especially among the UNIX
community that's uni X and for for games
and probably the best-known of the games
was a multiplayer global simulation game
called Empire which caused a few people
to drop out of school because they just
didn't have enough time for studies also
and in 1982 in April of 1982 I got a
call from George Lucas's people asking
if I'd be interested in starting a new
enterprise for him outside the film
business now the background for that is
that the movie business you spend a lot
of money for three or four years and
then suddenly over maybe a two-week
period
millions and millions of dollars come
flooding in and they'll go right back
out as tax unless you find out what I
use for them
that would be a good expense and a lot
of people just bought a movie company
just bought land or something but George
really invested it in the business and
when the the proceeds from Empire
Strikes Back came in he formed the
computer division which out of which
came later came things like Pixar at
enjoyed sonic solutions droid works when
the next movie Revenge of the Jedi which
then had to become Return of the Jedi
for political reasons came in needed to
expand further in some direction and
took the first step outside the movie
business but the idea being to do sort
of modern technology in the
entertainment industry outside of the
films and the assumption was that that
would probably be B games but we needed
to kind of determine that he offered the
job was offered to a number of people a
number of graphics hotshots and they all
turned it down because although it
sounded like a lot of fun it wasn't real
work it was just kind of playing around
and their you know wouldn't be any real
future in it and how would it look on a
resume and I didn't have these
compunctions so when it was offered to
me I took the job and my goals I think
were to use modern technology in in the
games business to be fair console games
at that point we're pretty pretty basic
pretty crude the graphics were blocky
and aliased music was whiny and
repetitive game physics was awkward at
best and the gangs had to run on
machines like the Atari 2600 which was a
6502 processor with 128 bytes of RAM now
128 bytes it was interesting because
most of the people in the business at
that point didn't think of it as 100
a bytes they thought of it as a thousand
24 bits because you wouldn't use a whole
byte if he only needed like 7 bits and
so we came in with kind of a more of a
tools approach we used larger computers
to to model and to compile programs to
run on the little on the 6502 s and
other small program computers and so I
hired computer professionals who had a
kind of a tools approach and had an
aptitude for using various computer
languages ability to create computer
languages when needed of course we took
advantage of the experts right next door
in storytelling computing graphics sound
editing and I wanted to create an
environment that specifically encouraged
allowed and then encouraged creativity
rather than making marketing deadlines
as it happened just by coincidence
our marketing deadlines kept falling
away by other people's problems
and to the point where we were begging
for people to release our things which I
probably a first and I tried to I tried
to have managed the group as a group of
peers so that when David Fox came to me
with a great game idea and I told him
that'll never work he was at the perfect
position to ignore me and go ahead put
that in the game and it ended up being
like one of the most memorable parts of
the game and I'm glad that that was the
situation I would have felt terrible if
he had not done it we'd lost that we
took in a million dollars our first year
we didn't actually make any products the
first year we made tools and I think
that that really worked out well for us
to test the tools and our development
concepts we made to throw away game
throw away and those throw away games I
think partly because of the environment
we had already set up ended up doing
things that gain no games had done
before in one game we had music being
composed on the fly and played on the
fly music that that told you what was
going on in the game in places where you
couldn't see and at the same time we had
antialiased graphics being generated in
real time on a 6502 processor we had one
magazine interviewer come to interview
us and while we were demoing the game he
started looking under the table in the
closet saying okay where's the video
disk player said no no no we're
generating it here said no no you can't
do that
so the I think that approach already got
us off on a good start and those those
games of course became ball blazer and
rescue and practice and speaking of
which let's take a quick look at rescue
and my apologies by the way it is purely
my lack of technical skill and lack of
time and preparation that thinks some of
the bottoms of these videos are cut off
alright one of the more memorable
moments there never works so I've got a
picture here you see David here in the
center and Peter next to him and other
members of our group that couldn't make
it or couldn't fit on the stage but this
was the games group in fact just as I
joined so this is what I remember of the
the guys that I first met there and
David was my first contact he was really
the the dad of the group in the sense
that he actually you know had a family
and that was a bad thing for all of us
why something
David why don't you talk a little bit
about making those first games in
particular I mean it's it's not apparent
now you know as Peter says it was just
shocking to see this sort of 3d
first-person point of view that it so
commonplace now that none of us had ever
seen before never none of us thought was
possible on a computer like that and how
did you get that in there and then what
were your thoughts right well I'm going
back just a bit before that I was
working on a book called computer Anna
yeah computer animation primer and as
part of the research I was able to
connect with the Lucasfilm computer
division and hang around with a bunch of
those brilliant guys including Lauren
carpenter who is known at the time for
doing you know fractals that he's the
one sending with a checkered shirt right
behind me and mmm he was he did the
tracklist for the Genesis effect on a
Star Trek 2 movie where you see the
planet being terraformed and a year
later when my book was completed I
happen to hear that
this new group was starting up a games
group within Lucasfilm and being in the
neighborhood and having already met at a
mall and bunch of people I called him up
right away and he said yeah well we're
about to hire this guy Peter and whoa
soon as he comes on board we'll let him
interview you I brought my manuscript
completed manuscript to show him and
because I was working with the Atari
computer that and we were gonna be doing
Atari games that was a really great
readin for me getting the job so is the
second person hired third person in the
group there's another person already in
the company I guess the first game
designer and other than Peter and I they
didn't have our space up yet so I was
put in an office with Lauren and I you
know right in the beginning I asked him
said hey you know is there any chance
that we could do a facto based
first-person game on an Atari 800 he
said no no isn't how are you kidding and
I guess I sparked some interest he came
back the next morning he said well you
know it actually might be a way to do it
and we loaned him an Atari he learned
6502 like overnight came back in a day
or two with a working demo and that
became the basis for the game so I had a
you know then immediately put game
around this this landscape I'm really I
wanted to be a Star Wars game originally
and we were told right up front when I
asked that we were not allowed to do
Star Wars titles and that was I was
really upset I joined the company
because I wanted to be in Star Wars and
that was the closest way I could do it
was to you know it's the create a game
and then do it that way but I know it
quickly had to change the the concept
and when we finally showed this to
George I think in the summer both we
both got about 20 minutes to sit with
him while we give you damn elect me and
able to be in furball blazer
and one of the things he noticed was
that I didn't have a fire button in the
game because I wanted to make this a
really you know peace-loving game and
and am I kill anyone and the way you
were supposed to kill people was by
getting them to follow you and and then
make sharp turns and had them crash into
the mountains and you know he said no
give me a fire button and the other
thing he suggested was you know
sometimes adding some tension to the
game by possibly having some of the
pilots you pick up be be the aliens that
you're trying to destroy and first we
thought it wasn't going to be doable and
then we thought about it for a while and
and came up with this concept of having
the the Jaggi monster pop up and start
smashing the screen like you just saw
and we were really lucky in that Atari
listened to our marketing requests and
did not say anything or put any pictures
of that in any of their press and we
kept it a surprise and that the thing
didn't happen until you were on level 8
and we had other than the baculum annual
where there was a like a transcript of a
pilot who who's getting screaming and
stuff when she's been getting smashed
and eaten we kept a secret and I so get
letters from people remembering the
first time this Jackie monster popped I
mean they've been playing the game
casually for eight levels and all of a
sudden this thing happens and people
would fall out other seeds there's a kid
who ran out of the house screaming
there's a monster in my computer I heard
young people at college and in the dark
with their sound turned up really loud
you know really would crash and keep
what we run in and say you know you
scream and crash off of their charity
okay okay so it's I guess the first game
that really actually really scared
people not just you know made Jim Jeff
and
that was that was a lot of fun so yeah
now it actually probably scares people
more when they see a paywall in their
game but all right well the next video I
have is kind of a twofer one going to
introduce both of our next two guests
partly because you're there's a lot of
people have seen the old games but
there's one that hasn't gotten a lot of
publicity and you'll you'll see how that
was presented to our our company we
would get all of Lucasfilm together once
a year and I have to set the stage a bit
in that here we get a company meeting
where each of the different groups and
divisions and the company shows what
they've been up to in the last year and
invariably ILM would go before us and
show the best you know five minutes of
all their special effects that they had
done for you know the biggest
blockbusters full screen and and then we
would project in in 1980s technology so
it's like a tiny little portion of the
screen we'd get this little projection
of our computer screen stuff with our
little jaggies and it was you know kind
of humiliating at the time but we were
interactive and we were also able to
show the people a little glimpse of the
future of you know hey you know computer
games may actually get a little bigger
sometime so you listen for the the
numbers quoted in in this video here
hi there I'm Steve Arnold talking to you
live from a popular night club in
habitat a fantasy world made possible by
the miracle of telecommunications
habitat we'll connect people from all
over the country into a single imaginary
cartoon reality using a Commodore 64
computer a modem and a telephone habitat
which could be the world's first 10,000
player computer game is currently in the
final testing stages and will be
available later this year now let me
show you what else we've been up to one
of the products we shipped last year was
a game based on the movie labyrinth the
player must traverse the labyrinth
within 13 hours solving puzzles and
avoiding goblins to confront jerath in
the center of his castle or be doomed
for eternity as one of Jarrett's slaves
well it's almost like the movie the
other new game we shipped last year was
phm Pegasus a high-speed strategy action
game that puts the player in command of
a military hydrofoil in eight scenarios
around the world this is our first entry
into the popular simulation category of
games we've been very happy with the
success of Pegasus so we are developing
a new scenario disc as a separate
product that will provide 10 additional
adventures for the Pegasus player maniac
mansion a new kind of comedy adventure
game is scheduled to be on the shelves
this fall you direct a trio of teenagers
in the exploration of a Victorian
mansion trying to rescue a friend who is
being held captive to save her you must
outwit a crazy doctor who is scheming to
take over the world one teenager at a
time maniac mansion is the first game we
published ourselves and we're already
hard at work on some other exciting
projects in education and entertainment
that we'll be able to show you next year
let's get a candid reaction to all this
here's a man standing in front of
habitats Oracle fountain excuse me sir
what do you think it's great
we'll hear more about habitat in a bit
but we're going to now switch over to
Steve who came in and Steve was had been
working at Atari which obviously was a
good background I just say what when I
was hired at the company I was the the
first game developer they brought in who
actually had experience in the game
industry before and that was a big count
against me they felt that you know in
1984 I was probably too set in my ways
of the old way of doing video games and
we needed something new but Steve's a
Atari background to help run the company
was helpful I personally also think one
of the major factors that helped out is
that before he did that he was a
practicing child psychologist and
managing a group of game developers
that's I can think of very few training
regimens that are better than that but
now Steve has gone on to do quite a bit
of stuff as with VP at Microsoft but has
been a venture capitalists for some time
and working with a lot of startups so
he's in a great position to talk about
what it was like when we were starting
up as this small company within a bigger
company and also some perspective on
what that's like in in today's world so
Steve so you probably gathered that the
joke with George was that when we were
presenting to him that was frequently
the reaction you got he would look at
something and he'd consider it very
deeply and then he'd say great that was
it but getting a great was a good
outcome when you were presenting to
George so anyway it was fun to see that
old stuff that I haven't seen that in
ages so let me take a couple of
perspectives on the question that Noah
asked which is what was it about
Lucasfilm games that that might have
gave us an opportunity to do some
innovative stuff and I guess I've
reflected on a little bit and thought
it's it's probably a combination of the
background in Atari and and psychology
but there were a couple of other
principles that I think we adopted one
of which Peter alluded to earlier which
was we were creating a culture that was
designed around innovation and I I think
David and I have come to agree although
he was just
at the beginning I actually think one of
the really good constraints we had is
that we were not working with Star Wars
we had the brand of Star Wars and the
credibility of Star Wars and the
franchise of Star Wars but we didn't
have to play in that universe so what
happened is we were a group that lived
inside of a super creative
technologically astute company and we
got to do our own invention we got to do
our own creation we were the literally
probably the only group outside of
George inside of the Lucasfilm company
that actually got to make up new stories
and call them Lucasfilm and so that gave
us a fair amount of freedom and a fair
amount of flexibility and also a fair
amount of challenge but I think that
really helped us I would argue that that
helped us another thing that happened
and this is a little bit amusing
reflecting on it many years later but I
was brought in as the general manager of
the group with the idea of trying to
figure out how we were going to go from
a research group to a development group
a publishing group without losing the
kernels of creativity and innovation
that was started by Peter and David and
of several other members of the team who
aren't here when I first met with George
about and I got hired by the computer
division folks and I met with George he
said to me he said stay small be the
best and don't lose any money now the
good news about that that sounds a
little mundane at one level but the good
news about that is actually was actually
an incredibly liberating mandate because
it really gave us permission and we
didn't actually stay small completely
but we stayed pretty small for a while
but we were really driving towards
trying to figure out how could we take
the franchise of that people were
associating with George and Lucasfilm
which was innovative storytelling apply
it to this new interactive world and and
so we we invented lots of different
things because we had permission to do
that I'll throw in one other thing and
then toss it back and maybe we'll talk
about more of this stuff more later one
other thing we did intentionally and
this goes specifically to the question
could you do it today because we were
sort of an indie the equivalent of an
indie film company we were a little more
artsy and not only driven by commercial
success we certainly wanted to make
games that people liked and bought but
we also wanted to make stuff that we
thought and that people thought was
innovative and pushed the edge of the
envelope and the intersection of
Technology creativity storytelling
graphics animation all those dimensions
and so we developed a culture that was
extraordinarily collaborative and as
Peter said we almost never even though
we tried to make our deadlines we almost
never sacrificed fun ativy which was our
joking way of saying is the game any fun
for a ship date and we gave ourselves
permission to do that because we always
figured that if we knew a better way to
do it and that certain point we had to
push it out the door but if we knew a
better way to do it or if they knew a
better way to do it
it was worth trying to figure out
whether we could actually make it better
make it more fun make it more engaging
and we gave ourselves permission to do
that for quite a long time so thanks
Steve Yann I'll say Steve Woodall often
asked us you know what's the fun
activity quotient you know of a concept
that was running by one of the slide you
you may see that will be hitting later
shows that we had many concepts that we
never actually put into production just
throwing ideas out discussing them and I
I have since come to realize that part
of what Steve was getting us to do was
think about what now is thought of his
metrics and is very routine but at the
time you know even thinking would this
be fun was was slightly radical it was
more a matter of hey am I having fun
making this and well we'll just throw it
out there and see what happens but
trying to see if there was some way of
measuring that was was a new thing so
you saw a bit of habitat in action that
was a really groundbreaking unusual
thing at the time you have to realize
these were you know Commodore 64's
you know running at one megahertz
you know clock speed you know yes one
megahertz and with 300 baud modems which
is incredibly slow data rates and yet
our next speaker
Morningstar who also looks slightly
different you know some of us have
changed slightly he came in as our tools
programmer originally but had this great
idea and I'd like chip to talk a little
bit about you know some of the pressures
he felt with that and you know what was
going on when he came up with this idea
of it's a radical idea in fact chip if
you look online is one of the people who
had to coin the term avatar in its
current sense because up until then we
never had to describe what this
character is is not really you but you
kind of control them but you know it was
a radical new concept at the time so
chip tell us about it well I mean you
start out talking about the Commodore 64
and it's kind of like you know these
little things about you know well I had
to walk barefoot through the snow 18
miles you know each way uphill in the
dark you know past bandits and mountain
lions well actually a mountain lions
part is true but we actually had
mountain lion sit but you know the
reality is we were we were attempting
something kind of crazy and we had sort
of the freedom to do that because we had
the Lucasfilm brand behind us and there
was something to the the glamor
associated with Star Wars and the whole
Lucasfilm
universe that we were able to capitalize
on quite shamelessly and people would
come to us just wanting to sort of bask
in the reflected glory of Star Wars and
companies would be coming through all
the time and one of the things that
happened is people in the group would
come up with ideas and and write them up
and Steve would keep a file full of this
stuff and when some company would come
wandering through to you know Steve
would pull a couple of ideas out of the
idea file and see if he could sell them
on kicking us some money to develop it
and so we ended up getting and what's
sort of one other one of the rules we
operated in a sort of a coral layer if
that stays small be the best and don't
lose any money principle was we kind of
never did anything with the company's
own money we always had to get somebody
else to pay for it and so we ended up
getting very creative in some of the
Neels we made and one of them was a
company called quantum link which was
doing a consumer-oriented online service
for owners of Commodore 64 computers and
they had just had a big strategic
investment from Commodore International
and they were looking around for well
what can we do with this with the
service that we've got they had some
interesting things they've done to bring
the cost down quite radically and and so
I had had this project proposal that I
cooked up in conversation with NOAA to
actually really really started out we
were discussing AI and I said well you
know we can never we don't know how to
create an atomic on which is as rich and
exciting and interesting and smart as a
real human being so what if we just
actually connected you to other real
human beings and it kind of went from
there and so the guy from Commodore
comes in and Steve pulls this proposal
out of the out of the file cabinet and
lo and behold the guys excited and
discussions negotiations start several
months later we have a deal and off
we're going and now all of a sudden oh
you have to actually produce this thing
as my idea there we go and then one of
the things that's interesting about the
group is it was kind of radically
egalitarian in that sense that everybody
had kind of the the time instructor was
flat you know all of the developers the
title was designer slash programmer
except for Gary who was an artist slash
designer or something like that
everybody was entitled to contribute and
so even though I was the tools guy I was
just as much in the mix of the creative
discussions as anybody else was and so
when this project got the green light
there I was and now I started to get a
learn by fire advanced training in a
project management and ended up doing a
whole bunch of stuff that looking back
on it it was kind of like what were we
thinking but in fact ended up inventing
a bunch of really interesting
distributed systems technology that I
continue to make use of to this day
I'm now on like the eighth generation
the server but it's all based on the
same fundamental architecture just just
doing crazy stuff on a Commodore 64 like
demand paged object-oriented virtual
memory off of a floppy disk
you know real-time packet-switched data
communications over 300 baud modem and
all of that stuff and you'd look at that
stuff now and you say you know you can't
do that we didn't know you couldn't do
that so we just went and did it and it
and it worked and there's a lot to be
said for just pushing the envelope
you're here
well-put and following from that you
know part of that egalitarian thing and
all of us sharing ideas there was a
point and I'll let Ron delve into it but
he was talking to chip about creating
languages and you know what could be
done - we were very interested
having been attracted to Lucasfilm
because of Star Wars for the most part
and of course Indiana Jones was was
quite big and fresh still still coming
out with new movies then and we were
very interested in doing interactive
storytelling and Ron had some ideas
about that that led to what is now
infamous scum the script creation
utility for Maniac Mansion and maniac
mansion
Ron did a great post-mortem on that at a
previous GDC but maybe he can tell us a
little bit more about what happened with
his development of that and how he was
given some freedom to explore what was
next an interactive storytelling yeah I
think you know my my biggest memory from
developing you know the scum system for
maniac mansion was what felt like to me
at the time was almost getting fired by
Steve because I yo Gary and I I had
worked on Noah's game coronis rift I was
hired to do the port from the Atari 800
to the comet of 64 and while I was doing
that I befriended Gary Winnick who's on
the
- right can't tell which right and we
you know came up with this idea for this
game called maniac mansion mostly
because we liked you know be horror
movies and so we started working on it
and I think we'd probably worked on it
for maybe nine months and Gary and I had
a design and the code was going nowhere
because you know I was trying to code
the entire thing in 6502 assembly
language which really was not working
and I remember at some point Steve
called me into his office and I remember
we had a talking - I know about the the
the state of the game and how it was not
progressing very far and I also think
this is the point that David Fox was
brought on to the project as a script er
and I think that's because Steve felt
that the project needed an adult but as
I was you know kind of fumbling around
with the 6502 stuff I was I was talking
to chip and you know chip had suggested
well why don't you do like a scripting
language and you know build a compiler
and an interpreter and I mean all this
seemed crazy to me on a Commodore 64
it's you know to write all this stuff
but you know chip actually convinced me
that this would be doable and I think
chip went off and wrote the first comp
compiler over lunch which was very
impressive a couple of days you know and
really from that you know came this
whole adventure game scripting language
which you know obviously went on to live
you know power most of the Lucasfilm
adventures you know maniac mansion Zack
McCracken and Monkey Island and salmon
Max and and all of those games but you
know I think you know as other people
have mentioned I think it was that that
environment we had which was very
collaborative and everybody worked
together and there was this there was
this kind of sense well except for me
worried about getting fired there was
this like there wasn't this fear of
failure at some levels and it really
kind of allowed you to go off and do
really interesting things and you know
as chip had mentioned I think a lot of
the stuff we did we were just kind of
too stupid to know that
couldn't be done and so we would just
kind of go and do all of these you know
really interesting things yep
well I've got a little bit of animation
from Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
that David and Ron and I led together
just to give you a sense of what that
was like for those you in the audience
all Vanger puzzle was scum
hey does anybody remember why you needed
to do that I guess so
okay so I think we're gonna go through a
little yeah who's that that handsome guy
on the right boy I figured I better
humiliate myself as long as I've been
doing it to everybody else on that
what's that stuff on the top of your
head yeah I got it oh yeah I've been
replacing it with hardware it's actually
much easier to groom and also a nod to
Eric whoa Mandir in the middle there who
was also instrumental in habitat but you
know came in on the Coronis rift team
early on as as Ron did so I'm going to
let this run through a bunch of slides
now as we talk about some of the other
issues that have come up and this as I
expected you know we've taken a little
longer than I thought we would but we're
gonna leave some time for Q&A so if
people have really burning questions
we've got some microphones out there and
we're gonna I'm gonna ask the panel a
question or two but if I start to see
people accumulating there I'll turn it
over to you guys so feel free to stand
up by the microphones and in a few
minutes we'll get to that one of the
questions though I wanted to throw out
to the panel anybody want to jump up on
this is George himself you know as
you've heard was directly involved
although really let us experiment quite
a bit both in the ways you've heard and
also in the fact that he spent probably
a total of I don't know two or three
hours every year working with our group
directly which we you know felt
neglected at the time and yet as with
the Luther with the Star Wars thing in
retrospect I think maybe there was a
benefit to that because he didn't impose
any vision on us as Steve mentioned we
were really lucky in the company of
being able to be creative people with
the name Lucasfilm stamped on what we
did and not have it come directly from
George but does anybody else have any
any thoughts on that of what he was
doing and how it worked for us well one
of the things I noticed was and and it
really only became more aware of this
after the fact is because
we weren't allowed to touch any of the
Lucasfilm properties initially Star Wars
Indiana Jones any of those which the
company viewed as money in the bank
because they could turn around and
license those for top dollar to other
game companies and take the licensing
fee and not take any of the risk we were
kind of forced by default to do our own
creative stuff on our own which
unbeknownst to me at the time turned out
to be the source of a lot of jealousy
and other parts of the company because
here we were getting to create our own
stuff and all these other really
creative really capable people were
forced to march to George's vision
any other thoughts about that yeah when
we when we later spent some time with
Lucas arts I recognized a real
difference in the feel of the company in
that they were now constrained by
scripts other people had written and had
to had to make games that they had some
creative creative input to but for the
most part that general arc was all
determined for them ahead of time and I
think it I think that took a lot of the
fire out of it I was really glad I was I
was conscious at the time that this was
a boon to us that we could we could
watch what say Atari was doing with the
license things and even make comments
like this isn't good enough
you know Princess Leia is ugly and this
and needs to be prettier or whatever but
we didn't have to write those scripts
ourselves so I think one of one of my
earliest you know first memory actually
of meeting George Lucas was this was
right after the 10th anniversary of Star
Wars and George and Steven Spielberg had
shaved off their beards so they could
sneak into a showing of the Star Wars
thing and not notice and that was like
so the first time that I met George
I met a George Lucas without a beard and
I really kind of felt I felt ripped off
I wasn't meeting that iconic George
Lucas with a beard so I think I think
that will stick with me so yes you know
it all comes down to facial hair I guess
in the end so something I like to ask
and I think I'd like to start with you
Steve since you've been somebody who's
been hearing a lot of pitches that the I
just wonder whether the factors that
kind of aligned for us does it feel to
you that that was you know unique and
and a chance or do you think that that
could be sort of engineered and you know
company pitches and startups today do
you think that that kind of feeling
could be recreated it's an interesting
question one of my experiences since
Lucasfilm games was I was in the venture
capital business for a long time so
that's the context that no is asking
about in terms of thinking about
dynamics of startups and I think one of
the core one of the benefits we had
which is what I said earlier about the
notion that we've got to adopt this
indie spirit we got to push ourselves to
figure out what was interesting or what
was fallen or what was creative and the
business context gave us permission to
do that and I guess one of the questions
I would have for the companies of today
is whether or not those room for that
kind of innovation try something new
rather than do something bigger harder
faster that we've already done a bunch
of times if that is something that
people are willing to allow there is a
significant amount of innovation in the
game business today but there's also a
significant amount of repetition rep
replication of models that have been
tried and true and so if there was one
window that I think we gave ourselves it
was the chance to try something new who
knew you couldn't do communication on
300 baud modems right we said well what
the heck let's try it and we did as chip
said convince somebody else to pay for
it so in that sense it had a little bit
of that startup mentality we pitched we
basically had to pitch these ideas
either to an Atari to fund us or to
Commodore or somebody else but in the
context of that there was the chain
to say we think we can do this we
actually don't know if we can do it but
if we could it would be worth it so I
guess that might be a way to think about
whether that spirit exists someplace and
probably in indie Studios that are
innovating and happily you're at the
cost to build stuff today at least on
some platforms is substantially less
than it was in our day but on other
platforms is hugely greater I mean we
did our mega games for a few hundred
thousand dollars and I some of you guys
are spending twenty five million dollars
on a game today well I mean that was
completely cheap once yeah what's a bit
cheap one points exactly I mean that was
completely unheard of and so that gate
that was another constraint I guess that
pushed us to try to figure out what all
we could get done with on a relatively
constrained environment and David you've
been doing you know some unity
development recently and in that same
sense do you think there's anything
about those those sort of old methods
that could be applied to companies today
or game development today I think the
big thing that we we had there was you
know was this support of the team and I
don't think that's really technology
dependent and people mention that a few
times like you know whenever we had a
game concept it would be passed around
all the other game designers and plus
other people who were kind of key people
and we meet and we talk and we give
feedback and some not not as much thumbs
up thumbs down but you know like you
know this is this is a great idea this
should go forward and I haven't seen
that much you know other places where
I've been where where it was really
feeling of support of everyone we wasn't
you know if he gets his and I won't get
mine it wasn't that kind of competition
so a real sense I mean we don't go to
lunch all the time at the ranch should
we just go to the main house and have
lunch and talk and
that without that there that support
from all the creative people who were
there I think what happened wouldn't it
happened yeah well let me just add one
thing to that rumor some of you have
heard the rumor that all of the first
ten Pixar movies were planned by the
team in one afternoon sitting over lunch
or something and then they sort of
delivered them but there was that sense
of creative collaboration at Pixar that
resulted in a very different spirit of
creativity than what had been known up
to that point in the movie business and
although we didn't do all of ours in one
afternoon we did something very similar
which was what David was talking about
it was a very collaborative process and
it wasn't a process of somebody else
judging it was somebody else making
somebody else's idea better it was every
game is a Lucasfilm game all of us do
this and so that I think allowed us to
push not only storytelling and and new
models of maybe the the maniac mansion
interface for example probably looks
clunky to you guys today but in those
days it was a massive innovation to be
able to actually allow you to construct
interesting ways to have characters do
things using that kind of language based
interface and a bunch of people
contributed to that idea Ron and his
team actually built it but it was
something that everybody could pitch in
on and same thing happened with little
bits of code somebody would write a a 3d
scaling algorithm for a character in one
game and then we'd be talking about it
somebody said Oh what we could probably
retrofit that and fit it in over here
and all of a sudden components of tools
or development capacity is also being an
cross fertilized among teams so
everybody had a sense of helping
everybody's game be better there is you
know what I remember was not competition
within the group but I feel like we were
competing with the rest of the company
you know always I am with film that film
part and you know one thing we really
remember was going to one of the early
consumer electronics shows and I think
this is when rescue and Bob lazer first
being shown and just walking around the
floor
if someone was looking at our game I was
really impressed and said wow this is
really great Lucasfilm games is there
anything else your company does so it
was the first time I felt like we were
being judged on our games rather than
comparing him to the film's and that was
really nice
no I was with David at that time there
was just a quite a revelation just
really it really has to stand on her own
that way and this was this was a good
tit-for-tat for for the time when when I
think some magazine said that this was
you know the best graphics ever ever
produced in a video game and I believe
Alvy Ray Smith said it's the worst
graphics ever came out of lucasville so
you've been patient I'm gonna throw it
open to the audience and you've been
standing for a long time thank you
thanks Noah whoa that's love hey I'm
Alex handy from the Art Museum of Art
and digital entertainment I just wanted
to let everybody know you can play some
of these games over at Moscone West on
the second floor we have all blazer and
maniac mansion as well as the rest of
your history but I have questions for
chip of course who probably expected my
questions chip you have to cross-compile
habitat on the vos server right so like
did you guys start developing that on
the c64 or did you start it on vos
because well the vos was used for the
server the development environment for
all of the Atari and Commodore and Apple
basically all of the home computer games
was the the host was a UNIX system
variously various VAX is and Sun
workstations and that sort of thing in
fact the the job that I was actually
originally hired to do was to replace
the macro assembler because they they
when I when I interview they said well
we have that we have the world's most
powerful 6502 macro assembler it's
written in list
and you know it requires two megabytes
of memory on our half megabyte VAX and
so it's really slow and but you can use
all of Lisp as your macro language so
it's really powerful so we'd like you to
replace it with a more traditional
assembler but oh by the way we don't
want to give up any of the power and so
and so we did a lot of cross compilation
cross development stuff but it was all
things like Sun workstations with
special hardware that led us reach into
the memory of the like the Commodore 64
we had a cartridge that plugged in and
lets you rewrite the memory on the fly
and interrogate it and do all of this
stuff from much much more powerful Sun
workstation which was pretty radical for
the time and and I'll give another shout
out to Alex's museum they're a I've
talking to him the other day and they
got an amazing amount of stuff up and
running that I never would have believed
was possible to do all these years later
it's a kind of a computer archaeology
that I think will be more and more
important as time goes on yeah he
mentioned vos I think they're actually
trying to get habitat running again
which which if they can pull it off well
I'll just be we're working on it
awesomely impressed the thing that add
one more tidbit the thing that killed
habitat actually was it was too popular
the deal that we had with quantum link
which became America online was that
they had ran the back-end servers and
chip and his team created the front-end
and they just had a handful of a
relatively small number of people
playing the game when it was first in
beta test the first multiplayer online
game and the fact of the matter is with
this small handful of people relatively
speaking it was driving so much volume
on their system that they actually had
to shut it down because at three dollars
and sixty cents an hour which is what
the cost used to be per hour for premium
services on America Online they couldn't
make any money so it actually was never
brought out commercially in spite of the
fact that it had all those innovations
yeah I'm not actually sure that that's
strictly speaking true because they
they were struggling with how do you
market this thing because it was so
strange and they didn't have the
vocabulary to talk about it and so they
were constantly struggling to figure out
how do we explain this to people how do
they they all I agree with him they
didn't know how to talk about it yeah
and as a result there was always a there
was always a faction at at qlink that
said we don't we don't want to deal with
this because we don't know next question
hi I'm John Walker from Rock Paper
Shotgun first of all I just want to say
thank you for so much my childhood I
want to do ask one of my fondest
memories I would be looking through the
manuals and there would be that line in
there that said this'll slide big at
Sierra that our games won't kill you and
these David so I was wondering if you
could talk maybe about how the
competition with Sierra inspired your
games and how whether they influenced
you or whether there was any sort of
arms race between the two it's a great
question anybody want to jump in on that
yeah you know the with the adventure
games specifically we were in this
intense competition once again we were
in a competition and I think I thinkwell
okay and I think most of it was just
that they sold so much better than we
did
I mean King's Quest sold maybe ten times
you know what maniac mentioned it and so
there was always this this kind of
competition to you know do better than
them but it was all very friendly we
actually had a baseball game with them
when we worked up at Skywalker Ranch
there was a softball field and so we
invited Sierra to come up and you know
we had a friendly softball game one
Saturday which they won I'm not bitter
or anything but but yeah I think their
success you know at least for the groups
doing the adventure games they're their
success really drove us to try to do
better I think that maybe the
distribution wasn't as good in Europe
but in Europe our games did way better
than theirs did apparently yeah and
thank you Germany in particular where
our sales rates were literally ten to
one per capita what they were in the
u.s. is quite amazing yeah
I'm famous in Japan it was actually true
yeah I brought Ron out to Germany and
people were showing him tattoos of
maniac mansion the Monkey Island I guess
yes next question
hey um apologies for this being a little
bit of a story but it's like three
sentences
it's 2004 I in an early virtual world
I've met this girl online I'm chatting
to her on AOL Instant Messenger Monkey
Island comes up and there's a pause as
we both type the two messages come at
the same time and it's you fight like a
dairy farmer how appropriate you fight
like a cow and I'd like to think that's
how we knew subsequently moved out to
California we've been happily married
for two years thank you for changing
lives in the small and big ways um the
if I have a question it's really about
the adventure gaming genre and whether
it worked best in the sort of low
fidelity kind of 8 16 32 Birds sort of
you know growing medium and a bit like
kind of you know humour in particular
seems to work incredibly well and things
like South Park maybe even more so than
in even higher fidelity zones like
Family Guy you know et cetera um how do
you think with very high fidelity media
like you know the full 3d engines unreal
you know for running in the browser you
can get humor across in the medium best
and that's to anyone who wants to talk
about I think Ron has to at least say
something about that I I think humor you
know humor and adventure games is really
important because if you really think
about an adventure game you're doing
completely ridiculous things and it
helps it you can kind of poke fun at
those things you know if you're doing a
game it's a comedy you can have a rubber
chicken with a pulley in the middle and
nobody really questions that
some degree where if you're doing a
really serious game and you have
something strange you know people
there's a suspension of disbelief that's
kind of lost and I think that look goes
a little bit back to the fidelity issue
is as you are you know doing these
strange things I think if you have a
lower fidelity you know more cartoonish
you can kind of get that stuff across
more and you know we really don't have
the technology to do this ultra realism
right now without you know hitting that
uncanny valley thing so that's why I you
know personally enjoy art that's a lot
more stylized not so cartoony but
stylized and I've got to throw in I have
a very fond memory of that very
brainstorming session it's so much fun
our brainstorming sessions but we were
talking about monkey island and talking
about how are you gonna you know get guy
brush to go down there and we said oh we
could slide on a rope and we're saying
well we need something you know to to
you know hook over the rope so it
doesn't burn his hands and somebody said
you know what about a rubber chicken and
we got had a very serious discussion
about the fact yeah but a rubber chicken
you know the rubber will catch on the
rope and you won't really be able to
slide and would that be funny or do
something and yeah I guess it just won't
work and and honestly I don't remember
who even said this but somebody popped
up and said Oh what about a rubber
chicken with a pulley in the middle we
just cracked up and you know bang was in
the game at that moment but low is one
of my favorite brainstorm moments I
think we have time for just one more
question
I remain from Halfbrick first of all
thanks so much for the inspiration as a
French kid I had to learn English just
to play your games and that was great I
want to ask you if you were doing the
company again nowadays would you do
different would you try to create crazy
new epic technology would you try to go
procedural MMO crazy thing I mean or
would you just take today's tools and
create what you want
you have a million dollars pardon that's
it I was just gonna ask do you have
eight million dollars we can answer that
question for you now question was what
would we do anything different we still
try all the crazy stuff yeah more crazy
stuff it would have to be more crazy now
yeah yeah no I think we're in agreement
on that you know that you know this is
an amazing time a more technology I
think than we've ever seen before and it
just gives you more range to try stuff
absolutely bizarre and and as chip says
things that everyone is sure can't
possibly work because that's where all
the cool stuff but shows up so I'm going
to call it at that thank you very much
for attending and thank your panel here